ME
AN, TAKE U WHAHA
HERE.
>> ALISY, UNL NOW
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLEO
UNDER A
T RE
N'S LAWYERS FROM
STORY OFT HAPPENS
G PROTRA LEGAL FOR
ITA JUDGE  ORRESPONNT BARBARA IS
CENG WAS
SPECULATIVE AN -
UNANCHORED. BEGS  JULY 02E JUST
STAT
O MONTHS OF BARBA
STARR'S E- RECORDS FROM
W,T THE TIME A
R OF 2020, CNNTYER,M HIS ISLIMI.
THE COURT AND ASKS FOR THIS E R
ITIATENS
OF THOUSANDSE-MAILS.
IT INCLUDED E-ECDS INTERNAL, N
ANYT TY NT OFFICIAL THATEEN THEI
NVESTIGATION THAT
ABOU
INL JUDGAN SE JUSTICE
MENT SHOUL T
THMENT RETURNS TO THE JUDGE WIT
COULD T EVEN SEE AND PERSUAD
E JUDGE TOEIS DEMANDR BARBARA SL
IN NOVEMBER, TO
ANOTHEE, AND I GET A SULT FA FE
ANTHONY  WHOESH
O NARROW THE SCOPE HE REQUEST.
CONNECTED  EVIDENC
RELEVANT MATERIAL ORL MENT'S ASA
GH THE FIRST
AM TT
RELATES TOINUARY O2021E LASTW DM
MINISTRAE JUSTICE
PABACK TO THDGE ANGE
ER, BECAUSE HE SAYINATNN
TO NARW THE SCOPOFS QU
PRESIDENT ONAN
TED NUMBER O RECORDS
Y  THE
GOVERNMENTDYM ITF ESCOMMUNICATI.
IN MAYLAST MONTHHEN THE
JUICLY
INFORMATION BARBARA R, WHO KEPT
THROUGH THIS ENTIRE  BY
BARBARA STARR I
MENTLLY NOTIFIED T
-E EC
R R ATPHONES, AS
WEE E-MAILS SOMETHING THAT'S COE
DARK ABOUTIL
WAN MI BARBA
STBOUT T TSTICE DEPARTMENT ARMAH
ALEEALED. HA
A VERY EXTRAORDINARY LEGGOING O.
EVAN, THR YOU THAT.
BRIAO MANY
ES
WE KNOAT CNNS T THE  AGE BT OF C
R A GAG DE L
R TIMESITUATION,
CN SUBJEG ORDER, OURS SILENT
FOR AN EVEERIOD OF
TIME. REVION E GOVERN SIN
JOURNALIRYTO DO IT
HAALISTSNDTHEIR KNOWNE, N
JOURNALISTS IS AN AFFRONT TO TEE
IT'S SO
EMBARRASSING, BUT THIS HAS BYEA.
NUMBER, TH THAT THE
JOURNALIAW ABOUT THE CASE, CAN'
RMF URS
SOMETHINEXTRAOARCREDIBLY UNUSUA.
" DON'T BELONGE
OUTLET.B IS TSPK THE TRUTH
GOING.
WHEN THEY GO OUR
CONFIDENTIAL RECORDS AND THESE G
S TO
CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHEITER TRUMS
YOE OST" WERE THE
OUTLETS THAT PMP ALIST RECORDST
T ERY TURN ON EVERY
OCCASION.
IS
HIS A
TARGETING THESE -- LOOK, -
>> ALLAIQU
ON FOR SO LONG, WHY ARE WE
FINDING OUT ABOUT IT?
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT UNDER MCK
GARLAND SAID THEY WEREOI
REVIEW OF A F CASES, SO
ATTHATY  OE WEEKEND THEM MAKING
THEY WER THIS EXTRAORDINEA.WINGR
>>ME THE
BIDEN ADMINISTTI
WILL NOT CONTINUE WE THIS IS NOO
WELL, ONLY IN THE LAST FEW WEET
THAT WASY IN RESPONSE TO A ROM
ARS  THE NEWS CAME OUT THAT
THP ADMINISTRATION WAS
ETIS IS SOMETHINTH
E STUDYI A
LOE, B
UNUSUAL.'SMBE ADMINISTRATIONANT
J ISNDER PRE
MAKE THIS 'S THE BIDEN DING
QUESTIONS, BUTO PUT
PRACTICE FOR FUT
ADMINISTRATIONS.
THIS, AND OFOUN DOJ COUL NOT TO
S EEN ATTORNEY RAAND AND ESENTA
THIS MATTED TRY TO BRI ION DOWN
LISTEN, I'EEN TALK TO GO
LAWYERS
THERE ACTUALLY WAS GAG ORDER T'E
BUT, I , AS SAYING, BIDEN TOOF
IN J.
HAS THE BIN DEPARTME OICE MOVED
ALACRI?HAS BEEN SLOONLY REASON
ABT THIS TODAY, CNN WENTO A
ND ASK
THE GA THE
CNN LAWYER TO EVEN TELL MORE
BRIAN ISHT, IS A POLICY THPPINGY
TO MERRICK JUSTICE
'T KW
WHHE NEW RULES WILL BE.
ING THATS,
FRANKLY, JUST FOR NOW, AND SO
THESTIT GOIN
FORWARD IS GOING TO BE, IS THERE
ANANGEPARTMENT HANDLES THESE IN
I CAN TELL YOU REAIC
IN JUSCE
THERE'S A LOT OF ANGER AT THE
GARLAND CURTAILING TYPES O
Y OFFICIALS ST
THERE DON'T FEEL THIS IS T
L SETY SUFFER BECAUSE OF I BUT
BENG THIS E EIUTORIAL DISCON
TH I
ORDET Y WHENO